Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is only one man who can lead any worker's regime. He lives for your problems. He shares your ideals and your dream. He supports you, for he loves you, understands you, is one of you. If not, how could he love me? So that, of course, was Evita Dominic in the eponymous musical by
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告畅听、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。只有一个男人能领导任何工人的政权。他为你的人生难题而活。他与你共享理想与梦想。他支持你，因为他爱着你、理解你、与你感同身受。如果不是这样，他怎么会爱我呢？所以，这首歌当然就是由……唱出的伊薇塔·多明戈（Evita Dominic），出自同名音乐剧
Andrew Lloyd Webber and Tim Rice and she is appealing to the Descamisados the the poor of Argentina and saying that Peron is on their side and one of the things that I've really enjoyed about doing the series is seeing the way in which the story in the musical, which is probably the version of Evita's life that most people listening to this will be most familiar with, how it maps onto the reality, but also the way in which Tim Rice, who's such a brilliant lyricist, has kind of used the raw material. So there's a speech that Ava gives in 1949 basically it is in prose what those lyrics from the musical are the opposition says that it is fanaticism that I'm a fanatic for Peron and for
安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯（Andrew Lloyd Webber）和蒂姆·赖斯（Tim Rice），她正在向“无衫者”（Descamisados，阿根廷穷苦大众）呼吁，说庇隆（Peron）站在他们这边。而制作这个系列节目让我感到非常享受的一点，就是看到音乐剧中的故事——这可能是大多数听众对伊薇塔生平最熟悉的版本——是如何与现实相呼应的，同时也看到蒂姆·赖斯这位才华横溢的歌词作家是如何运用这些素材的。比如阿瓦（Ava，即伊薇塔）在1949年发表过的一次演讲，其内容基本上就是音乐剧那些歌词的散文版：反对派说这是狂热，说我对庇隆和
the people that I'm dangerous because I'm too sectarian and too fanatical on Peron's behalf but I answer them with Peron fanaticism is the wisdom of the spirit I say yes I am fanatically for Peron and for the Descamisados of the nation. So she is fusing the two and she's offering herself. She loves the Descamisados. She loves Peron. Perfect. Marriage made in heaven. It's why actually, in other circumstances, I would say your lamentable singing, I would
人民充满狂热，说我很危险，因为我对庇隆过于宗派化、过于狂热；但我用庇隆主义回击他们：狂热是精神的智慧。我说，是的，我就是对庇隆和全民族的无衫者狂热。所以她将两者融合在一起，并奉献了自己。她爱无衫者。她爱庇隆。完美。天作之合。这也是为什么在其他情况下，我会说你那糟糕的歌唱，我其实会
discourage it. But as you know, Tom, I really have encouraged you to sing in these episodes. I mean, I say that in all sincerity. I couldn't get enough of it. You've been begging me to sing. The West End musical, which is melodramatic, and its critics said that
劝阻你。但正如你所知，汤姆，在这几期节目里我其实一直鼓励你唱歌。我是说，我是真心这么说的。我真是听不够。你一直求着我唱歌。西区音乐剧带有强烈的故作姿态之感，当时的评论家也这样评价
of Andrew Lloyd Webber and Tim Rice's work at the time, but that matches perfectly the style of Peronist rhetoric. And her constant talk of love, of martyrdom, of sacrifice, which I think she got from the world of the tango,
安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯和蒂姆·赖斯的作品，但这与庇隆主义的言论风格完美契合。她不断谈论爱、殉道和牺牲，我认为这些灵感来自于探戈的世界，
from the soap operas that she had grown up doing from her teens onwards. I think that got from the world of the tango, from the soap operas that she had grown up doing from her teens onwards. I think that gives Peronism its unique flavor. It's that much more than any kind of policy proposals or anything like that. So last time, if you remember, we talked about how Ava and Juan Peron met, how his political career became stratospheric, how there was this great rally on the 17th of October 1945, which was almost like an act of communion between Peron and the masses. Dominic, important to say, has not brought Peron to power as yet.
来自于她从十几岁开始参演的肥皂剧。我认为正是这些，赋予了庇隆主义独特的风味。相比于任何具体的政策提议或类似的东西，这一点要重要得多。所以上一次，如果你们还记得的话，我们谈到了阿瓦和胡安·庇隆是如何相遇的，他的政治生涯是如何像火箭般腾飞的，以及1945年10月17日那场盛大的群众集会——那几乎就像是庇隆与群众之间的一场圣餐仪式。多明戈，必须指出的是，此时庇隆尚未真正掌握权力。
It has simply meant that he can run in the forthcoming election. Yeah, which is scheduled for February 1946. Peronism does have some substance. It's not just style. So there's an emphasis on social justice. This is what gives Peronism its name, the creed, justicialismo, which is justicialism, which is kind of impossible to translate in English. It sort of means nothing. There is obviously a very strong nationalistic element to it.
这意味着他只是能够参加即将到来的选举。是的，选举定于1946年2月举行。庇隆主义确实有一些实质内容，并非徒有其表。其中非常强调社会正义。这就是庇隆主义名称的由来——正义主义（Justicialismo），在英语中几乎无法翻译。它某种程度上什么也没说。当然，其中也有非常强烈的民族主义成分。
Kind of anglophobic nationalism, would you say? Yeah, definitely anglophobic. Britain is seen as the, it's not quite the colonial oppressor, but Britain is the country that owns the railways, the banks. It's the country that all of this oligarchic conservative elite in Buenos Aires look to, and that therefore the descalizados, the shirtless ones, the working classes, resent. So that is a big element of it. People have sometimes said, is it just italian fascism i think we explored some of this in the last episode and it is in style but peronism is
某种仇英的民族主义，你会这么说吗？是的，绝对是仇英。英国被视为——虽说不上是殖民压迫者，但英国是拥有铁路、银行的国家。它是布宜诺斯艾利斯所有这些寡头保守精英仰望的国家，因此，无衫者们——那些赤膊的工薪阶层对此感到愤恨。所以这是一个重要元素。人们有时会问，这只是意大利法西斯主义吗？我想我们在上一期节目中探讨过一部分，它在风格上确实如此，但庇隆主义
also about delivering genuine benefits to the working classes i think that makes it different it's not particularly although it can be rhetorically very violent it's not about violence it's about ritual spectacle but also welfare public I mean, in a way, Dominic, would you say it's not far off the kind of the trend in continental European politics at the moment, actually, that it's very kind of statist concern with what might be cast traditionally as left-wing politics, but with an emphasis on the primacy of the nation and patriotism. It's actually a kind of a programme that lots of people looking at our own general election has said is missing, but quite a lot of people in britain would quite possibly identify with i think so i think it's basically uh people often joke don't know they say um the the sweet spot of british
同样也关乎为工薪阶层带来切实的利益，我认为这正是它的不同之处。它并不特别——尽管它在言论上可能非常暴力——它无关暴力，而是关于仪式感、奇观，还有福利、公共……从某种意义上说，多明戈，你会不会觉得这其实与目前欧洲大陆政治的某种趋势相去甚远？那种对传统上可能被归为左翼政治的事物的高度国家主义关注，但同时又强调民族至上和爱国主义。实际上，这正是许多人在审视我们自己的大选时所说缺失的纲领，但英国相当多的人很可能会对此产生共鸣。
politics is to hang child molesters and give loads of money to the nhs yeah and that's basically peronism yeah there's a bit of that in peronism i think you could you could make comparison between peron and some of the sort of authoritarian strongmen, Erdogan, Orban, and so on. People who wrap themselves in the flag, they have a client base to whom they give benefits. Fascist is not quite the right word, but there are elements, maybe, that are similar. And I think Peron absolutely has that. Just to reiterate, the one thing perhaps that really distinguishes it is the quality of emotion. I mean, you could call it histrionic if you're negative or operatic if you're being positive, but it's very, very kind of heightened rhetoric, isn't it? And of course,
我也这么认为，基本上……人们经常开玩笑，对吧？他们会说，英国政治的“甜蜜点”就是绞死虐待儿童的人，然后给国民保健署（NHS）大把大把地送钱。是的，这基本上就是庇隆主义。是的，庇隆主义里确实有那么一点这方面的影子。我认为你可以把庇隆与某些威权强人进行比较，比如埃尔多安、欧尔班等等。这些人把自己裹在国旗里，他们拥有一个能从中获得利益的客户群。“法西斯”这个词或许不太准确，但其中可能确实有一些相似的元素。我认为庇隆完全具备这一点。重申一下，真正让它与众不同的，或许正是情感的特质。我的意思是，如果你持消极态度，可以称之为戏剧化（histrionic）；如果你持积极态度，可以称之为歌剧化（operatic）；但这种言论非常非常高亢，不是吗？当然，
in the 1940s, a lot of people see this as very suspect. We talked before about the great writer Jorge Luis Borges. Borges is typical of a kind of Argentine elite who think this is Nazism. And actually, the opponents of Perón in the election in 1946, so the socialists, the communists, the radicals, they come together to form something called the Unión Democrática. Their emblem is the Phrygian cap of liberty, and their slogan is for liberty against Nazism. And of course, the man who is spurring them on is the former US ambassador with his excellent name, Spruill Braden, who says Perron is a Nazi, which I think is unfair because I don't think he is a Nazi. I mean, this is something that Churchill had said in the British general election, that Labour would introduce the Gestapo. Now it's happening
在20世纪40年代，许多人对此深表怀疑。我们之前谈到过伟大的作家豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯（Jorge Luis Borges）。博尔赫斯就是那种阿根廷精英的典型代表，他们认为这就是纳粹主义。事实上，1946年选举中庇隆的反对者——也就是社会主义者、共产党人、激进派——联合起来组成了一个名为“民主联盟”（Unión Democrática）的组织。他们的标志是代表自由的弗里吉亚帽（Phrygian cap），他们的口号是“为了自由，反对纳粹”。当然，在背后推波助澜的是前美国驻阿根廷大使，有着一个绝妙名字的斯普鲁伊尔·布雷登（Spruill Braden），他说庇隆是个纳粹。我认为这很不公平，因为我觉得他根本不是纳粹。这就好比丘吉尔在英国大选中曾说过工党会引入盖世太保一样。而在1946年，人们竟然
in 1946 that people are accusing their opponents of being Nazis. I mean, this is obviously a tradition in the post-war democratic world that will run and run and run. And I think there's another kind of interesting way in which this election that Perron conducts is looking forward to the future, which is his obsession with taking off his jacket. I mean, politicians are still doing that today, aren't they? They kind of get out on the stump. Tony Blair loved to take a jacket off. Yeah, they're always rolling up their sleeves and that kind of thing. Perron does that and he's the first person to have done it. He does all this campaign on trains.
开始指责对手是纳粹。我的意思是，这显然是战后民主世界的一个传统，而且会没完没了地持续下去。我认为庇隆进行的这次选举，还有另一个有趣的面向，预示了未来的走向，那就是他对脱掉夹克衫的痴迷。我的意思是，政客们今天依然在这么做，对吧？他们会去基层拉选票。托尼·布莱尔就喜欢脱掉夹克。是的，他们总是卷起袖子之类的。庇隆就是这么做的，而且他是第一个这么干的人。他所有的竞选活动都是坐着火车进行的。
He goes all over the country. Of course, Argentina, a massive country. He goes to Rosarium and Doza Cordoba on the train with Ava at his side. It's the first time a candidate's wife has travelled with a presidential candidate. So again, that is something that elections in subsequent decades will also pick up on. Totally. Yeah. She doesn't say anything, by the way. So she's not giving speeches for him. She's just standing there looking ornamental while he is giving these kind of hoarse speeches. It's a sign of Peronism's weird ambiguity and kind of slight meaninglessness that he is attacking the
他走遍了整个国家。当然，阿根廷是个幅员辽阔的国家。他和阿瓦一起坐着火车去罗萨里奥、门多萨、科尔多瓦。这是候选人的妻子第一次陪同总统候选人出行。所以这也是未来几十年竞选活动会效仿的一个做法。完全正确。是的。顺便说一句，她什么也没说。所以她并不是在替他发表演讲。她只是站在那里充当花瓶，而他则发表着那些嘶哑的演讲。庇隆主义那种诡异的模糊性和某种程度上的空洞性，就体现在他一边在攻击
opposition. He says they're socialists, they're communists, they're oligarchs, and they're weird ambiguity and kind of slight meaninglessness that he is attacking the opposition he says they're socialists they're communists they're oligarchs and they're working for the united states and people say hurrah these are these are obviously terrible people and he says again basically me or spruill braden he actually says the choice is this the real choice is between braden and perron and on braden's side it is the oligarchic communist ticket. A political scientist reading this would be like, what? That is just babble. These are communists and polo-playing, faux-British kind of bankers are.
反对派——他说他们是社会主义者、共产党人、寡头，而且还在为美国效力——而人们则欢呼，觉得这些人显然是十恶不赦的坏蛋；而他再次宣称，基本上要么选我，要么选斯普鲁伊尔·布雷登。他实际上说，真正的抉择是在布雷登和庇隆之间，而站在布雷登一边的是寡头与共产党的联合阵脚。一个政治学学者读到这里一定会想：什么？这简直是胡言乱语。这些共产党人和打马球、假装英国人的银行家们……
But they both occupy a place in the kind of demonology of the Argentine working classes. Well, also, I mean, Perón can occupy the centre ground. He can attack his opponents both as being extreme left and extreme right. That's exactly what he wants to do. He does it brilliantly. He wins a big majority. He wins 52% of the vote in February 1946. His party, which he has created really for the occasion,
但他们都在阿根廷工薪阶层的恶魔谱系中占据着一席之地。嗯，而且，庇隆能够占据中间立场。他既可以攻击对手是极左，又可以攻击他们是极右。这正是他想要做的。他干得极其漂亮。他在1946年2月赢得了压倒性多数，获得了52%的选票。他真正为这次选举创建的政党——
the Labour Party, party of the trade unions, win loads of Senate seats and governorships and all of that kind of stuff. And it is clear that he has built this extraordinary, very broad coalition. Of course, the problem with any coalition so broad is that you're trying to please everybody. However, Dominic, he has a wonderful wife in the form of Ava. And shortly before his inauguration, she broadcasts the entire future course of the Peron government in a daring sartorial maneuver when she goes to this banquet and she sat down next to the cardinal
工党，即工会政党——赢得了大量的参议院席位、州长职位以及诸如此类的东西。很显然，他已经建立起了一个非凡的、非常广泛的联盟。当然，任何如此广泛的联盟都会面临一个问题，那就是你试图取悦所有人。然而，多明格，他有一位了不起的妻子阿瓦。就在他就职典礼前不久，她在一次宴会上通过一个大胆的服装剪裁动作，预示了庇隆政府未来的全部走向：她出席宴会时坐在红衣主教旁边，
and she wears an off-the-shoulder dress. It's a bit like Jean Shrimpton wearing that mini dress at Melbourne, if you remember. It is. So it ranks alongside that as one of the two great moments in world history. So the elite alongside that as one of the two great moments in world history. So the elite, again, are very shocked by this. To sit next to a cardinal and to leave your shoulder bare.
穿了一件露肩连衣裙。这有点像让·什rimpton（Jean Shrimpton）当年在墨尔本穿那条迷你裙一样，如果你还记得的话。确实如此。所以它与那件事并列为世界历史上的两大高光时刻。因此，精英阶层再次对此感到震惊。居然敢坐在红衣主教旁边，还把肩膀露出来。
Incredible scenes. Particularly since this is one of the very few moments when Ava is slightly overweight. Overweight? Tom, I can't believe you've done that. We're not about fat shaming on the rest of history.
简直是不可思议的场面。尤其是考虑到这是阿瓦体型稍微有点微胖的极少数几个时期之一。微胖？汤姆，我不敢相信你居然会这么说。我们《历史的余烬》可不搞身材羞辱那一套。
Yes. I mean, I'm merely reporting what maybe hostile comments were said about her. Okay. So I want to distance I'm merely reporting what maybe hostile comments were said about. Okay. So I want to distance myself from this lack of gallantry, by the way.
是的。我是说，我只是在转述当时针对她的那些充满敌意的评论罢了。好吧。所以我想拉开距离……我只是在转述当时针对她的那些充满敌意的评论。好吧。顺便说一句，我想与这种缺乏绅士风度的行为划清界限。
Anyway, so Perron is in power. But Dominic, also, you've missed out the other key thing that happens shortly after the inauguration. Hold on. Were you the same person as the Tom Holland
无论如何，庇隆掌权了。但是，多明格，你也漏掉了就职典礼后不久发生的另一个关键事件。等等。你还是那个汤姆·霍兰吗？
who five minutes before we started recording was begging me to cut stuff out of the notes? Yeah, I know. But this is the best bit where after the inauguration, Perron goes and slides
就在我们开始录音前五分钟，还在苦苦哀求我把笔记里的内容删掉的那个人？是的，我承认。但这是最精彩的部分啊，就职典礼结束后，庇隆去滑楼梯了，不是吗？他还跟别人比赛呢。我确实把那段删了。但这是最精彩的部分啊，就职典礼结束后，庇隆去滑楼梯了，不是吗？他还跟别人比赛呢。我确实把那段删了。我特意把它删掉了。我想，听众没必要知道我们在那里滑楼梯。
down the staircase, doesn't he? And he's racing someone. I did cut that. But this is the best bit where after the inauguration, Perron goes and slides down the staircase, doesn't he? And he's racing someone. I did cut that. I deliberately cut that out. I thought, the audience don't need to know that we were sliding down there.
我觉得这展现了他非常棒的精神状态。如果我是总统，而且我有一座巨大的楼梯，我也会这么干的。好吧，现在好了，你跟所有人都分享了。庇隆接管阿根廷时，
I think it shows him in a very good form. If I was president and I had an enormous staircase, I would do that. Well, it's now, you've shared it with everybody. Perron takes over Argentina
正值一个极其有利的时机。他们没有卷入第二次世界大战，并因此变得极其富有。他们本来就已经很富有了。
at a very propitious moment. They have stayed out of the Second World War and they've become enormously rich. They're very rich War and they've become enormously rich. They're very rich already. They've become enormously rich. Britain alone owes them $2 billion,
他们变得极其富有。单单英国就欠他们20亿美元，
basically, for meat. Because of the collapse of the European economy because of the war, Europeans are desperate for Argentine products, cereals and meat and all that sort of stuff. At the same time, because European industries have been devastated, they're not producing goods for Argentina
基本上是买肉的钱。由于战争导致欧洲经济崩溃，欧洲人迫切需要阿根廷的农产品，包括谷物、肉类以及诸如此类的东西。与此同时，由于欧洲工业遭到毁灭性的破坏，他们无法生产出足够的产品让阿根廷去挥霍金钱。因此，阿根廷人不得不购买阿根廷本土制造的商品。所以这对阿根廷来说是稳赚不赔的。这太棒了。现在，这里存在一个隐患——如果你足够精明，在1946年就能预见到这一点——那就是欧洲终究会复苏。到那时，他们的农业会恢复生产，不再需要我们的全部物资；此外，他们还会生产出口给我们的商品，而我们则会把宝贵的外汇储备浪费在欧洲制造的收音机或诸如此类的东西上。与此同时，庇隆并没有考虑这些，他满脑子想的只是给自己的基本盘谋福利，所以他说：我要把很多英国铁路国有化，把那些产业国有化，我要推进工业化，
to waste its money on, as it were. So they have to buy Argentine-made goods. So it's win-win for Argentina. It's brilliant. Now, there's a danger, which if you are smart, you would be able to see in 1946, which is Europe will recover at that point. They'll have their own farming back up again. They won't need all our stuff. Plus, they will be making import stuff to export to us, and we will be wasting our valuable currency reserves on european made radios or whatever it might be in the meantime perron doesn't think about this he's just about giving benefits to his sort of base so he says i'm going to nationalize a lot of these british railways and nationalize those industries i'm going to industrialize
大家都会有可爱的养老金和丰厚的福利。你可以说，从这一切来看，他与20世纪30年代美国新政中的富兰克林·D·罗斯福（Franklin D. Roosevelt）、40年代英国工党政府，或是世界上许许多多社会民主主义政府并没有太大区别。但说句公道话，多明格，克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）的妻子可没有走上街头给老百姓发缝纫机。克莱门特·艾德礼的妻子是个保守党人。好吧，那就对了。
they're going to be like lovely pensions and nice benefits. And you could say in all this, he is not that dissimilar from Franklin D. Roosevelt in the New Deal in America in the 1930s or from the Labour government in Britain in the 1940s or so many social democratic governments around the world. But to be fair, Dominic, Clement Attlee's wife is kind of not going out onto the street and giving sewing machines to people clement atley's wife was a conservative well there you go so there you go yeah so this is what perron is offering is a wife who's kind of literally handing out stuff to people so what she does straight away which is absolutely extraordinary by the standards of argentine politics is avaon, who, don't forget, at the beginning of 1944, was a radio actress and
所以这就对了。是的，所以庇隆提供的，是一位会字面意义上给民众分发物资的妻子。因此她立刻着手去做了一件按阿根廷政治标准来看绝对非同寻常的事。艾薇塔（Evita）——别忘了，在1944年初，她还不过是一名广播剧演员，
nothing but a radio actress. When they come in in 1946, she moves into the Ministry of Labour. She establishes an office there, Peron's old kind of stronghold, and people queue up to see her, and she basically gives them things. That is her role. You need stuff for our new school. My child is sick. I need help know stuff for our new school my child is sick i need help getting a permit to do and do this but the great symbol is the sewing machine isn't it which again is so kind of moving because it's her remembering her mother and how her mother with her sewing machine was able to just about keep her head above water and of course the sewing machine associated with women so that's why it makes sense for her to be kind of handing that out. Now, is she doing this just because Perron
除此之外什么都不是。当他们在1946年上台后，她搬进了劳工部。她在那里设立了办公室——这里曾是庇隆的老据点——人们排着队来见她，而她基本上就是给他们发东西。这就是她的角色。你需要为我们的新学校购置物资吗？我的孩子生病了。我需要帮忙获取办理某事的许可……但最伟大的象征是缝纫机，不是吗？这再次让人动容，因为这是她对母亲的回忆，以及她的母亲当年如何仅凭一台缝纫机勉强维持生计。当然，缝纫机与女性紧密相关，所以由她来分发这个再合适不过了。现在，她这么做仅仅是因为庇隆
has told her to? I think she clearly loves it. She says again and again, she says, I've always wanted to be somebody. She tells one of her friends, I always wanted to cut a figure in history. And I think this is a new part for her and one in which she can pour her energies in a way she never has before. Do you think at this point that she is consciously thinking I could build up a power base here? No, I don't. I don't think actually at any point. Now, maybe some people listening to this will disagree. I don't believe that at any point she thought I want to build up a power base independent of my husband. No, no, no. that's not what I'm saying because she always sees herself as part of Perron, but she wants to be his partner in government as well as emotionally,
吩咐她这么做的吗？我认为她显然对此乐在其中。她一次又一次地表示，我一直渴望成为某个大人物。她对她的一个朋友说，我一直想在历史上留下浓墨重彩的一笔。我认为这是她的一个新角色，一个她可以倾注前所未有之精力的舞台。你认为此时此刻，她已经在有意识地思考“我可以在这里建立一个权力基础”吗？不，我不这么认为。事实上，我不认为在任何时候……现在，也许听这期节目的某些人会持不同意见，但我坚信，她在任何时候都没有想过“我想建立一个独立于我丈夫的权力基础”。不，不，不，我不是那个意思，因为她始终将自己视为庇隆的一部分，但她不仅在情感上，也想成为他在政府中的伙伴，
doesn't she? Do you think she's starting to think in those terms already at this point, or does that come later? No, I do think that, but I don't think she would get the opportunity unless he wanted it. It would be nice to say this is a story of an independent woman and unfettered female agency, but I think that would actually be wrong. I think if Perron hadn't wanted her to move into the Ministry of Labour to do all these things, she wouldn't have done it. Well, I mean, we said how Perron is instinctively more cautious than Ava. So he likes clearly to have Ava kind of testing the waters for him. So that's what's happening. But when Ava is handing stuff out, I mean, she's essentially building up a client base. And also she is establishing links with the unions on a kind of
不是吗？你认为她在这个时候就已经开始作此想了，还是说那是后来才有的事？不，我的确认为她有这种想法，但如果不是庇隆希望她这么做，她是不可能得到这个机会的。如果说这是一个关于独立女性和不受束缚的女性自主权的故事，那固然很美妙，但我认为这其实是错误的。我想，如果庇隆当时不希望她搬进劳工部去搞这些事情，她是绝不会去做的。嗯，我的意思是，我们说过庇隆在直觉上比阿瓦更加谨慎。所以他显然喜欢让阿瓦去替自己投石问路。所以这就是正在发生的事情。但当阿瓦在分发物资时，她的确是在实质性地建立一个客户关系网。而且，她与工会建立联系的紧密程度，
a closer basis than Peron had ever done. And over the course of time, Ava's links to the unions will become much stronger than Peron's, which isn't to say that she is opposed to Peron, quite the opposite. She would see herself as serving his purpose. But we said that when she first meets him, she is not political at all. And she ends up incredibly political. I mean, she proves to be brilliant at politics. I think there's a smartness, though, from Peron. Peron has to put somebody in that role.
也达到了庇隆从未有过的地步。随着时间的推移，阿瓦与工会的联系将变得比庇隆还要紧密得多——这并不是说她与庇隆作对，恰恰相反，她会将自己视为在为他的目标服务。但我们说过，她刚认识他时，对政治一窍不通。而她最终却变得极其精通政治。我的意思是，事实证明她在政治上是个天才。不过，我认为庇隆此举也体现了一种精明。庇隆必须安排一个人担任这个角色，
And whoever he puts in that role will build up a relationship with the unions and an independent power base of their own. One of the things that made him successful all the relationship with the unions and an independent power base of their own. One of the things that made him successful all the way from the 1940s to the 1970s is he's really good at playing off people against each other and maneuvering with rivals. He doesn't want anybody else to have that job. And for her to have that job is perfect for him because she is his creature. She's not elected in her own right. She's no threat to him.
而无论他把谁安插在这个位置上，那个人都会与工会建立关系，并培植出属于他们自己的独立权力基础。他在20世纪40年代到70年代之所以一直能够游刃有余的原因之一，就是他非常擅长挑拨离间、在竞争对手之间纵横捭阖。他不希望任何人也拥有那份工作。而让她来担任这个职位对他来说简直完美，因为她是他的附庸。她并非凭自身实力当选，对他的地位构不成任何威胁。所以这太棒了。而且我认为关于这一点还有另一个原因，汤姆，那就是通过把她放在那个位置上，她就成了他试图实现的目标的象征与化身——也就是让从农村到城市的广大进城务工人员实现阶层跃升。没错。所以那种带有布宜诺斯艾利斯贫民窟粗俗词汇的工人阶级口音——当年她的演艺界资助人曾极力劝她改掉——现在反而成了一种惊人的优势，不是吗？确实如此。如果你去听听布宜诺斯艾利斯艾薇塔·庇隆博物馆里她的声音录音——我得说，如果你曾经觉得美国总统图书馆或博物馆稍微有点过于
So great. And I think the one other thing about that, Tom, is that by putting her there, she is his creature. She's not elected in her own right. She's no threat to him. So great. And I think the one other thing about that, Tom, is that by putting her there, she is the symbol, she is the personification of what he's trying to achieve, which is the uplift of a working class migrant to the city. Right. And so that kind of working class accent with her kind of salty vocabulary that she's picked up in the slums of Buenos Aires and which her acting patrons had urged to get rid of now becomes an incredible advantage, doesn't it? It does. If you listen to recordings of her voice in the Eva Perón Museum in Buenos Aires, I have to say, if you ever thought American Presidential Library Museum was a little too
歌功颂德的话，那就去布宜诺斯艾利斯庇隆博物馆看看吧，你会以一种完全不同的眼光来看待它们，因为那感觉基本上就像是你被困在了一大缸以艾薇塔·庇隆为风味的糖浆里。她的声音在那些无休止的剪辑片段中不断回荡。她有一种刺耳的、略显单调的嗓音，老实说，这其实并不是一个很好听的声音。但在竞选造势中很管用，对吧？但它确实管用，对吧？管用是因为它传达的信息不加过滤、真实纯粹，是来自街头的心声。而且人们已经做好了倾听她的准备，因为大家对她的声音在广播里早已习以为常。
hagiographical, go to the Perón Museum of Buenos Aires and you will see them in a very different light because it's basically like you're trapped inside a massive vat of Ava Peron flavoured treacle. And her voice is kind of coming out all the time in these endless clips. And she has this kind of rasping, slightly monotonous, it's actually not a very pleasant voice, I have to say. But effective on the stump, right? But it works, right? It works because it is the message, which is it is unfiltered. It is authentic. It is the voice of the street. And people are already being primed to listen to her because she's familiar from the radio.
在广播里听惯了，没错。所以当时有很多势利眼，精英阶层声称只有他们家的下人才会去听阿瓦的广播。但当然，从阿瓦的角度来看，这简直完美，因为这正是庇隆想要争取的对象。从事家政服务的人数，远比雇用家政服务的人数要多。另一个遭人诟病的地方是她最初的穿着打扮。她与庇隆党内国会多数党领袖的妻子搭上了线。这个女人名叫莉莉安娜·瓜多（Liliana Guado），她确实写了一篇关于阿瓦在这些年里极其精彩的纪实。她说，你知道的，她当时根本不知道该穿什么，不知道该怎么打扮，于是她
Familiar from the radio, exactly. So there's a lot of snobbery about that, that kind of the elites say that it was only their servants who had listened to Ava's broadcasts. But of course, from Ava's purposes, that's perfect, because these are exactly the people that Peron is out to get. There are more people in domestic service than there are employing domestic servants. So another thing that people are very snobbish about is the way at first she dresses. She links up with the wife of Peron's kind of congressional majority leader. And this woman is called Liliana Guado, who writes a brilliant account actually of Ava in these years and she says you know she didn't know what to wear she didn't know how to dress so she
走进一家店里，汤姆，她寻找的当然是——珠光宝气的闪亮装饰，没错。所以她会走进去说：“我要打折，我要给我妈买件东西，我们以后再付钱。”然而支票却永远没有兑现。传言说，里奇·雅迪（Ricky Yardie）和他的助手们只要看到她出现在街头尽头，就会赶快喊：“快，我来不及藏起店里最好的东西了！”你注意到她有个男同闺蜜吗？她当然有啦。帕科·哈曼杜（Paco Hamandrou）。简直就像理查德·柯蒂斯（Richard Curtis）电影里走出来的人物。是的，确实如此。他是个异装癖服装设计师，他们俩关系非常亲密。
goes into this story and what she's looking for Tom is of course bling bling exactly so she she will go in and she'll say I want a discount I want something for my mother we'll pay you later and the check never comes and the story is that Ricky Yardie and his assistants, when he saw her coming at the end of the street, he'd say, quick, I can't hide all the best stuff. Did you see that she had a gay best friend? Of course she did. Paco Hamandrou. Like somebody from a Richard Curtis film. Yeah, really is. So he was a cross-dressing dress designer and they were very close.
所以她对这种浮华张扬毫无心理负担。她对这种事一点也不感到羞耻。当莉莉安娜·瓜多对她说“你是不是该穿得稍微低调一点，因为你看起来有点流于俗套”时，阿瓦回答：“不，这恰恰是重点。穷人们可不想让一个老气横秋、衣着寒酸的人来保护他们。他们对我抱有各种梦想，我绝不想让他们失望。”这基本上就是《阿根廷，别为我哭泣》这首歌所传达的核心。是的，没错。你知道的，盛装打扮，惊艳全场。
So she had no compunction about the sort of flamboyance. She had no shame about that. She said to Lilian Guado, when they said to her, do you want to just dress down a bit because you look a bit vulgar? And she said, no, that's the point. Poor people do not want someone to protect them who is old and dowdy. They all have their dreams about me and I don't want to let them down. And that's basically what Don't Cry For Me Argentina is about. Yes, exactly. You know, dressed up to the nines.
当然，音乐剧《艾薇塔》中另一首关于此事的著名歌曲就是《他们需要崇拜我，所以把我打扮成迪奥风》（They Need To Adore Me, So Christian Dior Me）。随着时间的推移，她的品味确实变得更加老练了，不是吗？不过就“庸俗”这一点而言，我们录制的第二期播客好像就是关于特朗普先生的。你当时将他与古罗马的共和派政客进行了比较。当然，在那个年代，这种大肆炫耀的庸俗作风非常对大众的胃口，正如在今天依然如此。她在这方面是个天才。我的意思是，她深知民众想要什么。
And of course, the other famous song in Evita about this is They Need To Adore Me, So Christian Dior Me. And her taste will become more sophisticated, won't it, in due course. But just on the vulgarity, the second podcast I think we ever did was about Mr. Trump. You made comparisons with Roman Republican politicians. And of course, in those days, ostentatious displays of vulgarity went down very well with the masses, as indeed they do today. She is brilliant at that. I mean, she knows that's what they want.
他们想要看到珠宝首饰。他们想要看到像他们一样出身的人登上了权力巅峰。没错。但随着她的品味变得更加老练，她也意识到自己完全可以做到这一点——她既能迎合无衫者，同时也能对她真正痛恨的那些人——精英阶层、寡头阶级——竖起中指。因为她实际上开始像他们那样穿衣打扮了。她确实得到了一个像阿根廷精英那样去欧洲的机会。这就是“把我打扮成迪奥风”这个灵感的来源。试想一下，如果你是那种会去隆尚赛马场或阿斯科特赛马会、是伦敦普拉茨俱乐部（Pratt's）或怀茨俱乐部（White's）的会员、习惯了去蔚蓝海岸度假的人，结果这个可怕的女人却做出了这种事——这就是阿根廷精英们的真实想法。因为在1947年，
They want to see the jewels. They want to see that somebody like them has got to the top. Right. But also as her tastes become more sophisticated, she realizes that she can do that, that she can appeal to the descamisadas, but also she can thumb her nose at the people she really detests, the elites, the oligarchical class, by actually dressing as they dress, because she does get this chance to do what the Argentine elites do, which is to go to Europe. This is where the Christian Diormi idea comes from. And imagine if you're the kind of person who goes to the racing at longshore ascot and you are a member of pratt's or white's in london and you're used to going to the cote d'azur and then this awful woman does this that's what the argentine elite think because in 1947
弗朗哥（Franco）自西班牙内战胜利以来，在西班牙一直处于完全被孤立的状态。他在盟国眼中是个不折不扣的不速之客（persona non grata）。而唯一曾经做过西班牙朋友的，就是阿根廷人。他对庇隆说：“我很希望能邀请你过来……你知道的，根本没人来西班牙。请来西班牙吧。”庇隆其实并不想去，因为尽管西班牙是阿根廷巨大的贸易伙伴，双方显然也有着深厚的文化和情感纽带，但庇隆——他虽然喜欢反美言论，但也想和美国人保持良好关系。他知道去访问西班牙会惹恼美国人。此外，他也并不喜欢弗朗哥，不是吗？纽带……庇隆他喜欢反美言论，但也想和美国人保持良好关系。他知道去访问西班牙会惹恼美国人。此外，他也并不喜欢弗朗哥，不是吗？没错，他根本不想去看望弗朗哥。他其实并不赞同弗朗哥的做法，认为弗朗哥手段过于暴力和残酷。所以，
franco has been completely isolated in spain since his victory in the spanish civil war he is very much persona non grata with the allies. And the only people who have ever been Spain's friends, the Argentines. And he says to Perón, I'd love to have you over to, you know, no one comes to Spain. Please come to Spain. Perón doesn't want to go because even though Spain is a big trading partner for Argentina and the obviously enormous cultural, emotional links, Perón, he likes anti-American rhetoric, but he also wants to keep in with the Americans. He knows that would annoy them. Also, he doesn't like Franco, does he? links perron he likes anti-american rhetoric but he also wants to keep in with the americans he knows that would annoy them also he doesn't like franco does he no and he doesn't want to go and see franco he doesn't really approve of franco thinks franco's been too violent and brutal so
为了避开这个难题，庇隆自己不去，但他会派阿瓦前往，这几乎就像是一场皇家巡视。而阿瓦对此欣喜若狂，因为这正是精英阶层的做派——去欧洲进行一次豪华小巡游。确实如此。这里有一个非常感人的小插曲：在她动身之前，一群作为她粉丝的极贫困妇女赶来看望她，并告诉阿瓦，说她应该把头发盘成发髻（chignon）。比起那种20世纪40年代高耸蓬松的发型，她应该走在时尚前沿。我不知道这个故事是否属实，但它非常有趣，印证了你刚才所说的：她看起来越像精英、越走在时尚前沿、装扮越昂贵，她就越能满足粉丝们的梦想。这正是她在巡访期间所做的，而发髻也成了她的标志性造型，不是吗？是的，人们渴望她成为童话故事里的角色，把她视为肥皂剧里的人物，他们知道她与自己感同身受，而他们也认同她。
the way to get around that perron won't go but he will send ava on almost like a kind of royal progress and she's delighted because of course this is the elite thing to do to go to europe on a little tour it is and one of the things that's a very touching anecdote, that before she goes, a group of kind of very poor women who are her fans turn up and they tell her, Ava, that she should wear her hair in a chignon. So rather than a kind of pompadour hairstyle, 1940s hairstyle, that she should be more cutting edge and i don't know whether that story is true but it is really interesting as showing what you were saying that the more kind of elite the more cutting edge the more expensive she looks the more she is fulfilling the dreams of her fan base and this is what she will do on her tour and the chignon becomes her signature look doesn't it yeah that people want her to be a character in a fairy tale they think of her as somebody from a soap opera they know that she identifies with them and they identify with her.
于是她前往西班牙。她以前从未坐过飞机，显然非常紧张。她给庇隆写了一封信，这封信我们至今还保留着：“噢，我好难过就要离开，因为我无法忍受离开你的生活。我太爱你了。我对你的感情简直是一种偶像崇拜。我不知道该如何表达我对你的爱，诸如此类……”
So she goes to Spain. She's never flown before. She's very nervous, apparently. She writes Per on this letter, which we have. Oh, I'm so sad to be leaving because I'm unable to live away from you. I love you so much. What I feel for you is a kind of idolatry. I don't know how to show what I feel for you, but all this.
我的意思是，这根本不像那种信……还记得周一倒垃圾吗？亚瑟周五要在本·法洛斯（Ben Fallows）家过夜。根本不是这种内容。是的。是的。这简直就是……记得刷你的辫子。
I mean, it's basically not like the letter that, remember the bins are on Monday. Arthur's got to sleep over on Friday at Ben Fallows' house. It's not all that. Yeah. Yeah. It's kind of, it's just absolutely. Remember to brush your braid.
满溢的情话，而且没完没了。就好像她被困在了肥皂剧的语境里，永远无法逃脱。她抵达了西班牙。现场一片欢腾。这是他们多年来接待的第一位贵宾。弗朗哥亲自到停机坪迎接她。我的意思是，弗朗哥以前还接待过谁？他接待过萨拉查（Salazar），接待过希特勒。所以这算不上是什么了不起的伴儿。因此他高兴极了。她在西班牙到处参观，他们授予她伊莎贝拉天主教大十字勋章（Grand Cross of Isabella the Catholic，费尔南德和伊莎贝拉，伊莎贝拉女王），
Gushing, and it goes on forever. It's like she's trapped in the soap opera idiom and can never escape. She gets to Spain. Great hullabaloo. The first guest they have had for years and years. Franco's there to meet her at the tarmac. I mean, who else has Franco ever met? He's met Salazar and he's met Hitler. So not exactly kind of great company. So he's delighted. She goes around Spain, they give her the grand cross of Isabella, you know, Ferdinand and Isabella, Isabella
现场聚集了号称数百万的庞大群众。嗯，所以阿瓦此行显然在做的一件事，就是大谈社会正义的主题。没错。自西班牙内战以来，西班牙就再也没听到过这样的言论了。当她开始谈论民主时，每个人都只能报以无力的微笑。因为弗朗哥不是把她打发去参观埃斯科里亚尔修道院（Escorial）——菲利普二世的宏伟宫殿——并对她说：“噢，你不可能参观完而不泪流满面的吗？”而艾薇塔则打了个赌，说自己绝对能看完而不哭。这是一个绝妙的故事。
la Cattollica, and this gigantic crowd, supposedly millions of people. Well, so one of the things that Ava presumably is doing is she's talking about themes of social justice. That's right. That haven't been heard in Spain since the civil war. Everyone just smiles weakly when she starts talking about democracy. Because doesn't Franco, he sends her off to look at the Escorial, the great palace of Philip II and says, oh, you won't be able to see it without bursting into tears. And Evita has this kind of bet that she'll be able to look at it. That's a brilliant story.
我没听说过这个。我没听过这个故事。然后她回来了，弗朗哥问她：“你哭了吗？”她回答：“我一点也没哭。恰恰相反，我在想，这地方作为孤儿院真是个好居所。”我得说，我可不想坐在她旁边。
I didn't hear that. I haven't heard that story. And then she comes back and Franco says, did you weep? And she says, I didn't weep at all. On the contrary, I thought what a wonderful home for orphans. I have to say, I wouldn't want to be. I'll be frank with you, Tom. I wouldn't want to be sitting next to her.
跟你说实话吧，汤姆，我可不想坐在她旁边。我会觉得这太烦人了。是的，但她是赢家，因为结果就是，弗朗哥输了赌局，不得不送给她一件来自普拉多博物馆（Prado）的无价挂毯。所以你看，她展现了她的爱心。她关心穷人，还顺便捞到了一张挂毯。是的。噢，她满脑子都是仁慈。
I'd find that very tiresome. Yeah, but she's the winner because as a result of this, you know, he's lost the bet. He has to give her a priceless tapestry from the Prado. So, you know, she's shown that she cares. She cares about the poor and she gets a tapestry. Yeah. Oh, she's all about kindness.
她一心扑在慈善上，对吧，汤姆？这难道不是很美好吗？是的。她没有去英国吗？我以为她收到过邀请呢。嗯，情况很复杂。英国工党议员不希望她来，因为他们说她跟弗朗哥是一伙的——弗朗哥是个恶魔般的家伙，而且她丈夫是个十足的法西斯分子，我们不欢迎她来。她本来是完全可以来的，事实上确实有邀请，当时甚至还讨论过跟当时的英国女王喝茶。也就是我们所熟知的女王母亲（Queen Mother）。但她把日程安排搞砸了。
She's all about being kind isn't she Tom isn't that nice yeah she doesn't go to Britain I thought she did get an invitation well it's complicated Labour MPs did not want her to come because they say they're pals with Franco who's a nightmare of a man and her husband is a complete fascist we don't want her to come she could have come and indeed there was an invitation there was talk of having tea with the Queen as was. So Queen Elizabeth, the person we knew as the Queen Mother. But she messes around with the schedule.
其实是她自己的错。当时王室成员正在巴尔莫勒尔堡（Balmoral）度假。她大发雷霆：“如果他们不在伦敦见我，我根本就不去了！”好吧，随便你，那就别来了。所以她没去。因此她错失了她人生中的最高光时刻之一。不过她确实去见了教皇，不是吗？
Actually, it's her fault. And the royal family are up in Balmoral. And she has a massive strop. If they're not going to see me in London, I'm not even going to come. Well, fine, don't come. So she didn't come. So she missed out on what would have been the highlights of her life. But she does meet the Pope, doesn't she?
而且她觉得教皇稍微冷落了她，因为只给了她20分钟。20分钟是女王的标准待遇。没错。但流传出来的报道却是，寡头们通过向梵蒂冈发送她的艳照来暗算她。我假设这不是真的吧？不，完全不是这回事。她获得了20分钟的会面。
And she feels that he slightly snubbed her because she only gets 20 minutes. 20 minutes is what a queen gets. Right. But this is the reports that come out are that oligarchs have kind of stitched her up by sending pornographic photos of her to the Vatican. I'm assuming this isn't true. No, that's not right at all. She gets 20 minutes.
意大利的共产党人对她进行了极其暴力的抗议。有趣的是，也有人为她抗议，高唱墨索里尼时代的口号和歌曲。换句话说，人们完全是通过意大利法西斯主义、20世纪30年代政治的有色眼镜来看待她的。嗯，而且她在当地受到的礼遇远不如在西班牙那么热情洋溢。毫无疑问。所以她肯定不会喜欢这样。不过在巴黎，情况要好一些。在巴黎，你知道的，法国政府官员在她面前表现得极其“法国作派”，亲吻她的手，赞美她的美貌。是的，滑溜溜的。而且她还跟克里斯蒂安·迪奥（Christian Dior）搭上了线。当你“搭上”时，我的意思是她穿他的衣服。我的意思是她把自己的三围尺寸留给了他。我的意思是，汤姆，你把你的三围尺寸留给……好吧，我现在穿的就是迪奥的，所以……
Communists in Italy protest very violently against her. Interestingly, people protest for her, sing Mussolini era slogans and songs and stuff. So in other words, people perceive her purely through the lens of kind of Italian fascists, 1930s politics. Well, also her treatment is a lot less effusive than it had been in Spain. Definitely. So she wouldn't like that. No. But in Paris, it's a bit better. Paris, you know, people in the French government go all French over her, kiss her hand, praise her beauty. Yeah, kind of lizard-y. And she shacks up with Christian Dior. When you say shacks up, I mean, she wears his clothes. What I mean by that is she leaves her measurements with him. mean tommy you've left your measurements with that well i'm wearing christian deal now so
大家都在看着呢，你真的跟迪奥搭上过线吗？我完全没有这种感觉……我穿它是为了向艾薇塔致敬，真不敢相信你竟然把自己的穿着告诉别人。好吧，这就是全部的意义所在，多明格，一切都关乎时尚。迪奥曾说过，他这辈子只为一位女王设计过服装，那就是艾薇塔。噢，他真的这么说过吗？他只为一位女王设计过服装，那就是艾薇塔。他真的说过吗？他真的说过。是的，他真的说过。我对这一点非常怀疑。
people are watching this on you did you shack up with christian deal i have no sense um i'm i'm wearing it in uh in avita's honor and i can't believe you're telling people what you're wearing well it's what it's all about dominic it's all about fashion he said that he had only ever designed clothes for one queen and that was avita oh did he really say that he had only ever designed clothes for one queen, and that was Evita. Did he really say that? He did. Yeah, he did. I'm very suspicious of that.
最后一个细节。她去了瑞士。事后每个人都说：“噢，她去瑞士显然是为了把大量偷来的钱存进瑞士银行账户。”正如我们优秀的传记作家尼古拉斯·弗雷泽（Nicholas Fraser）和玛丽莎·纳瓦罗（Marisa Navarro）所说的那样，比起会见瑞士外长并参观手表厂，要把钱存入瑞士账户有的是更方便、更不显眼的方法。
One last bit. She goes to Switzerland. Everybody afterwards says, oh, she obviously went to Switzerland to put loads of stolen money in a Swiss bank account. And as our excellent biographers, Nicholas Fraser and Marisa Navarro say, there are many more convenient and less conspicuous ways of depositing money in Swiss accounts than meeting the Swiss foreign minister and being shown around a watch factory.
所以……是的。这可能是个双重障眼法。很有可能是个双重障眼法。她回到了阿根廷。阿根廷人民欣喜若狂。她完成了一次宛如女王般的巡访。她是万众之心的女王，所有这一切……
So... Yes. It might be a double bluff. Could be a double bluff. She comes back to Argentina. The Argentines are delighted. She has made a kind of regal tour. She's the queen of hearts, all that kind of...
他们称之为“彩虹之旅”。彩虹之旅。万众倾倒，多明格。是的。有趣的是，英国报纸《观察家报》（Observer）对此事的评论其实相当精辟。
They call it the rainbow tour. The rainbow tour. High-flying of hearts, all that kind of... They call it the rainbow tour. The rainbow tour. High-flying adored, Dominic. Yeah. Interestingly, actually, the Observer, British paper, I think is quite good on this.
它写道：这是一场充满魅力的蛊惑人心之举。我认为他们并没有说错。现在，她当时在西班牙似乎还被指控行了法西斯礼，而事实上她当时只是……
So it says this was an exercise in glamour demagoguery. And I don't think they're really wrong. Now, she was accused, I think in Spain, of giving a fascist salute when actually she was
所以上面说这是一次关于魅力煽动术的练习。我觉得他们说得并没有错。当时她被指控，我记得是在西班牙，行法西斯礼，而实际上她
just kind of waving. And the Observer said, to us, the fascist salute means a nightmare that happened, but to Senora Perón, it evidently seems just a gesture in a great show, the theme of which is, poor girl makes good and is beloved by one and all forever and ever. And the Observer says that very scathingly.
只是在挥手。观察家说，对我们来说，法西斯礼节意味着曾经发生的一场噩梦，但对贝隆夫人来说，这显然只是伟大演出中的一个手势，这个演出的主题是，贫苦女孩飞黄腾达，并且受到所有人永远永远的爱戴。观察家对此进行了非常尖刻的评论。
But of course, that is the plot of the musical, of the film, and of Evita's life in her own mind, isn't it? Poor girl makes good and is beloved by one and all forever and ever. But is it? Because actually, the kind of the take on the film is pretty hostile to Evita. I mean, this is why Evita is such a polarizing figure. There are people who completely adore her. And there are people who see her as the most monstrous person imaginable. You know, that's why she's so her as the most monstrous person imaginable. You know,
但当然，这就是音乐剧、电影以及贝隆夫人自己心中构想的伊薇塔一生的剧情，不是吗？贫苦女孩飞黄腾达，并且受到所有人永远永远的爱戴。但真的是这样吗？因为事实上，这部电影对伊薇塔的看法是相当敌视的。我的意思是，这就是为什么伊薇塔是一个如此两极分化的政治人物。有人完全崇拜她。也有人把她看作是能想象到的最可怕的怪物。你知道，这就是为什么她是一个如此把她看作是能想象到的最可怕的怪物。你知道，
that's why she's so fascinating as a political figure. So I think, I mean, I think it's fair to say that when she comes back from her European tour, she's a figure of even greater glamour to her admirers in Argentina than she had been before. And she's a figure of immense interest to people around the world. I mean, I would say that she is on her way to becoming the second most powerful person in Argentina and, you know, by far the most powerful woman in global politics. So when we come back after the break, let's look at how she does this. Basically what she does as Evita rather than Ava. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
这就是为什么她作为一个政治人物如此引人入胜。所以我想，我的意思是，可以说当她结束欧洲之行归来时，在阿根廷崇拜者眼中，她的魅力比以前更大了。而且她成为了世界各地人们极为关注的人物。我的意思是，可以说她正在成为阿根廷第二权力人物，而且你知道，可以说是全球政治中最具权势的女性。因此，当我们休息回来后，让我们看看她是如何做到这一点的。基本上，她是以伊薇塔的身份做事，而不是阿娃。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的必听节目。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. And Dominic, we left Ava in the end of the first half saying that she is the most significant female political figure in world politics at this time. So the question is, is she doing anything specifically for women beyond giving them sewing machines? And the obvious question, Argentine women at this point do not have the vote. Is she working to give them the vote? Tom, as always in the rest of history,
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的剧集、独家番外并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《余下的历史》。多米尼克，我们在前半部分结束时提到，阿娃在当时是世界政治中最具分量的女性政治人物。所以问题是，除了给他们缝纫机之外，她有没有为女性做些什么具体的事情？显而易见的问题是，当时的阿根廷女性还没有投票权。她是否在为她们争取投票权而努力？汤姆，就像《余下的历史》一贯的风格一样，
the answer is yes and no. Is it? Is it complicated, Dominic? Is it complicated? It is always complicated. So she didn't vote in 1946 because she couldn't vote. There had been 15 attempts in almost 40 years to give Argentine women the vote and they had all failed one way or another. And is that because? Men are bastards. Well, men are bastards, but feminism, again, it's a bit like kind of shooting sticks and polo. It's something upper class. It's something that is associated with the elites. It doesn't seem to have had kind of deep grassroots fervor.
答案是有的，也没有。是吗？这很复杂吗，多米尼克？很复杂吗？事情总是很复杂的。所以她在1946年没有投票，因为她当时无法投票。在将近40年的时间里，阿根廷曾有15次尝试赋予女性投票权，但都以这样或那样的方式失败了。那是为什么呢？男人都是混蛋。嗯，男人确实是混蛋，但女权主义，这又有点像打野猎和马球。那是上流社会的东西。它是与精英阶层联系在一起的。它似乎并没有在基层激起那种深厚的热情。
I definitely don't think it has grassroots fervor. I think you're probably right. I mean, that's not, that's obviously the case in lots of places, that suffrage campaigns are led by generally quite well-heeled women. I think Argentina is, I mean, I don't want to just degenerate into kind of national stereotypes, but it's the land of the gaucho, it's a land of very kind of masculine machismo and so on. But if feminism is seen as something that is the kind of the property of the elites, and Evita will always deny that she's a feminist. I mean, in her biography, which,
我绝对不认为它有基层热情。我想你大概是对的。我的意思是，这并不是……在很多地方，争取选举权的运动通常都是由家境优渥的女性领导的，这显然是事实。我认为阿根廷是——我的意思是，我不想堕入那种国家刻板印象，但这是高乔人的土地，这是一个充斥着某种男子气概和极具大男子主义等等的地方。但是，如果女权主义被视为精英阶层的专属，而伊薇塔总是否认自己是女权主义者。我的意思是，在她的自传中，
you know, may have been, goes written for her, but clearly is expressing her sentiments. She says she wasn't a feminist because I wasn't an old spinster or ugly enough, which would obviously get her cancelled today. Yeah, it would. But it's the sense that she is appropriating that campaign and making it her own. Must be another way of sticking it to the upper classes. Oh, it is. Definitely. Perron, her husband, is in favour of giving Moon the vote. It's a brilliant way to get a lot of votes, right?
你知道，这可能是别人代笔的，但显然表达了她的心声。她说她不是女权主义者，因为我不是老处女，也没有丑到那个地步，这话拿到今天肯定会让她遭到取消。是的，确实会。但这种感觉是，她正在将那场运动据为己有，并打上自己的烙印。这一定又是打击上层阶级的一种方式。哦，确实如此。贝隆，也就是她的丈夫，赞成给予女性投票权。这是赢得大量选票的绝佳方式，对吧？
Yeah, of course. because they'd vote for him Yeah exactly Actually she lends her voice to a bill introduced by a supporter of hers called Eduardo Colom actually that bill is later dropped it's not the bill that goes through but she does make speeches you know saying it's time for women to have their say
对，当然。因为她们会投票给他。是的，完全如此。实际上，她为支持者爱德华多·科隆提出的一项法案发声，不过事实上该法案后来被搁置了，并不是最终通过的那项法案，但她确实发表了演讲，你知道，呼吁是时候让女性发出自己的声音了。
we love Perron let's all vote for him and all this kind of thing so she's a sort of supporting player I. What she does that is much bigger than that is actually setting up a women's party. So it is, of course, it's again, this double-edged issue. It is a Peronist women's party. And when she gives the speech in July 1949, where she says, I'm setting up this party, she says, the point of this party is unconditional loyalty to peron a man to be a peronist is to be loyal and have blind confidence in peron she says yeah and she says of her own role i have been nothing more than the bridge i desire to be between the workers and
我们爱贝隆，让我们都投票给他以及诸如此类的事情，所以她扮演的是一个配角的角色。她所做的更大的一件事实际上是建立了一个妇女党。所以，这当然又是一个双刃剑的问题。这是一个贝隆主义妇女党。当她在1949年7月发表演讲，宣布成立这个党派时，她说，这个党派的宗旨是对贝隆进行无条件的忠诚，作为一个贝隆主义者，就是要对贝隆忠诚并抱有盲目的信心，她是这么说的。是的，而且她谈到自己的角色时说，我不过是一座桥梁，我渴望成为工人们和
the general which again is not very feminist no i think i mean she's i mean i've seen this in her autobiography again no woman's movement will be glorious and lasting in the world if it does not give itself to the cause of a man so that sense of self-sacrifice is obviously a huge part of her kind of personal mythology she's never happier than when she's sacrificing herself for something and i think she genuinely thinks that is a woman's role in society. Okay, but so women's suffrage is past. But the other thing that she's doing, which we were talking about in the first half, is that she has this kind of program of relief of basically giving people stuff. The emblematic thing that she gives out is a sewing machine,
将军之间的桥梁，这同样也不是很女权主义。不，我认为——我的意思是，我又在她的自传中看到了这一点，世界上没有任何一个妇女运动，如果不把自己奉献给一个男人的事业，就能变得辉煌和持久。因此，这种自我牺牲的精神显然是她个人神话中非常重要的一部分。没有什么比为了某事而牺牲自己更让她感到快乐的了，而且我认为她发自内心地认为这就是女性在社会中的角色。好吧，既然妇女选举权已经通过了。但她正在做的另一件事，也就是我们在前半部分讨论过的，是她有这样一个救济项目，基本上就是给人们送东西。她分发的标志性物品是缝纫机，
because thereby women can have autonomy, they can have independence, they can make more money for themselves. And of course, she understands this to the depths of her heart because that had been true of her mother. And of course, she'd been a working woman herself, when she was an actress. Of course. In that sense, I mean, that is a feminist program, isn't it? Giving women the chance to stand up on their own feet. When we started this series in the very first episode, after you sang that extraordinary song at the beginning, we talked about Margaret Thatcher going to see Evita in the late 1970s.
因为这样女性就能拥有自主权，就能自立，就能为自己赚取更多的钱。当然，她对这一点有着刻骨铭心的理解，因为她的母亲就是这样。而且，当她还是个演员的时候，她自己也是个职业女性。当然。从这个意义上说，这确实是一个女权主义项目，不是吗？给女性站稳脚跟的机会。当我们在这档节目的第一集开启这个系列时，在你唱完开场那首非凡的歌曲之后，我们讨论了玛格丽特·撒切尔在20世纪70年代末去见伊薇塔的事。
Margaret Thatcher never called herself a feminist, distanced herself from feminism, but was a working wife who clearly blazes a trail for other women to follow. And I don't think, I mean, obviously they're very different, but there's a slight element of that here. But yeah, they are very different, but both of them are kind of publicly committed to the notion that women should have the chance to improve themselves, to advance themselves, to rise up in the world. Both of them, you know, coming from very different political standpoints are very keen on that. And I wonder if that is
玛格丽特·撒切尔从未称自己为女权主义者，她与女权主义保持距离，但她是一个职业妻子，显然为其他女性开辟了一条道路。我不认为——当然，她们非常不同，但这里面有那么一点类似的成分。但是的，她们截然不同，但两人都公开致力于这样一个观念：女性应该有机会提升自我、发展自我、在世界上崭露头角。无论两人的政治立场多么不同，她们都非常热衷于这一点。我在想，这是否是
a part of what makes them such iconic figures. Well, I mean, it definitely pays off in Argentina. Perón does really, really well with women in the next election. And the Peronist Women's Party is probably more committed, more vital, more dedicated than the men's. So she's very, very successful at establishing a lasting legacy. And we'll maybe talk later, actually, when we turn to this issue of social welfare, about how the woman is the dispenser of charity, the mother of the nation, the mother of the descamisados. That obviously plays into or plays on existing stereotypes, existing archetypes, I guess, of women in kind of Catholic iconography and in the kind of folk iconography of so many Argentines, don't you think? Yeah. I mean, she's brilliant at going
她们成为如此标志性人物的一部分原因？嗯，我的意思是，这在阿根廷确实得到了回报。在接下来的选举中，贝隆在女性选民中表现得非常非常好。贝隆主义妇女党可能比男性政党更坚定、更具活力、更具献身精神。因此，她在建立持久遗产方面取得了巨大成功。也许我们稍后会讨论，当我们转向社会福利这个话题时，关于女性如何成为慈善的施予者、国母、无衣者的母亲。这显然迎合或利用了现有的刻板印象，即天主教图像学中以及众多阿根廷人民间图像学中的女性现有原型，你不觉得吗？是的。我的意思是，她极其擅长顺应
with the grain of cultural expectations, but kind of refining it and kind of ratcheting things up. Exactly. So as we said before, in the first half, she had her office at the Ministry of Labour and people would come and she'd give them things and she loved that she loved being photographed giving clothes and food to the poor or her sewing machines or whatever she's getting more and more letters and so in 1948 they institutionalize it the maria eva duarte de peron foundation and this is basically it's so big it's like a government department she is spending the equivalent of about 200 million dollars a year they employ tens of thousands of workers construction workers priests they're giving out half a million sewing machines tom yeah yeah half a million pairs of shoes hundreds
文化期待的脉络，同时又将其提炼并推向新高度。没错。正如我们之前在前半部分所说，她的办公室设在劳工部，人们会来找她，她会给他们东西，她喜欢这样，她喜欢被拍摄向穷人发放衣服和食物、或者她的缝纫机之类的东西。她收到的信件越来越多，所以在1948年，他们将其制度化，成立了玛丽亚·伊娃·杜阿尔特·德贝隆基金会。这基本上是一个庞大的机构，就像一个政府部门，她每年花费相当于大约2亿美元的资金，雇佣了数万名工人、建筑工人、神父，他们分发了五十万台缝纫机，汤姆。
of thousands of cooking pots all of that stuff setting up orphanages and hospitals and schools and all these things so in the musical there's a kind of tone of cynicism around this. The idea that it's all a bit of a scam. And of course, people who were hostile to Evita said, oh, you know, it's just a way for her to better herself. I mean, this is where the money that she was supposedly depositing in Swiss bank accounts was coming from. That doesn't actually seem to be the case.
是的，是的，五十万双鞋，数十万口大锅，所有这些东西，建立孤儿院、医院和学校以及所有这些事情。所以在音乐剧中，围绕这一点有一种愤世嫉俗的基调。认为这一切都有点像是一场骗局。当然，敌视伊薇塔的人会说，哦，你知道，这只是她为了抬高自己身价的一种手段。我的意思是，她据称存入瑞士银行账户的资金就是这么来的。但这实际上似乎并非如此。
Actually, amazingly, it seems not really to have been very corrupt at all. I mean, maybe I've got this wrong, but that does seem to be the case. Actually, amazingly, it seems not really to have been very corrupt at all. I mean, maybe I've got this wrong, but that does seem to be, at least in part, down to the unbelievable hard work that Evita puts into it. I mean, she's really, really micromanaging it. She's going into work all the time. I mean, basically, she barely sees Peron. You know, she ends up moving into a different bed because they have completely different waking hours. And she's going around the country and she is perhaps getting an understanding of Argentina and its social problems that most politicians don't get. So there are kind of records of her going out and seeing, you know, the depths of poverty that some people are living in and bursting into tears and coming back and
事实上，令人惊奇的是，它似乎并没有多少腐败。我的意思是，也许我搞错了，但事实确实如此。事实上，令人惊奇的是，它似乎并没有多少腐败。我的意思是，也许我搞错了，但事实似乎是，至少有一部分要归功于伊薇塔投入的难以置信的辛勤工作。我的意思是，她真的在事无巨细地管理。她一直都在工作。我的意思是，基本上，她几乎见不到贝隆。你知道，她最后搬到了另一张床上睡，因为他们的作息时间完全不同。她到处走访全国各地，她对阿根廷及其社会问题的理解可能是一般政治家所无法企及的。所以有这样的记录，她出去看到了一些人生活在水深火热的贫困之中，然后失声痛哭，回来后
working even harder to try and relieve it. So I don't want to sound too much of a kind of Evita fanboy, but there is... That's too late, Tom. I think she comes across as a very impressive figure with this in a way that I had not been expecting her to, to be honest. Well, first of all, I think there is a bit of corruption, so I don't think it's uncorrupt.
更加努力地工作，试图缓解这种状况。所以我不想听起来太像一个伊薇塔的狂热粉丝，但这里面有……那已经太晚了，汤姆。我认为在这件事上，她展现出的形象非常令人印象深刻，老实说，这超出了我的预期。好吧，首先，我认为其中还是存在一些腐败的，所以我并不认为它是绝对廉洁的。
Of course, but she personally is not doing it to make herself rich. No, I don't think that's... She believes it passionately. Yeah, I mean, she's got a jaw. Yeah, but she's is not doing it to make herself rich. No, I don't think that's... She believes it passionately. Yeah, I mean, she's got a jaw. Yeah, but she's got a Christian Dior me. Got a Dior outfit. She doesn't need the money from the foundation. You're absolutely right.
当然，但她本人并不是为了让自己发财。不，我不认为那是……她对此深信不疑。是的，我的意思是，她有迪奥……是的，但她并不是为了让自己发财。不，我不认为那是……她对此深信不疑。是的，我的意思是，她有迪奥……是的，但她有迪奥的裙子。她不需要基金会的钱。你完全说对了。
She works ridiculous hours. She gives up an enormous amount of time. There's a moment when the novelist, the American novelist, John Dos Passos, in 1949, he goes to Argentina and he actually goes to see a day at her foundation and he says you know it's not particularly fancy the place is rammed it's so full of basically people in rags her desk is at the end and as soon as she comes in all the flashlights go off and there's the cameramen are all very excited and people are all crowding around and then basically she literally just she's listening to poor women's troubles and like
她工作的时间荒唐地长。她付出了大量的时间。有一次，美国小说家约翰·多斯·帕索斯在1949年去阿根廷时，他真的去参观了她基金会的一天工作，他说，你知道，这里并不特别豪华，里面挤满了人，到处都是衣衫褴褛的人，她的办公桌在尽头，她一进来，所有的闪光灯就都亮了，摄像师们都非常兴奋，人们一拥而上，然后基本上她就字面意义上地——她在听取可怜女人们的烦恼，比如
wiping the nose of their children and stuff. And she does that all day. And actually- You know what her role reminds me of? Is a medieval queen. Yeah, exactly. That's exactly what it's like. Tom, I think that is exactly the right comparison.
帮孩子们擦鼻涕之类的。她一整天都在做这个。事实上——你知道她的角色让我想起了什么吗？中世纪女王。是的，完全是这样。这完全就是那种感觉。汤姆，我认为这绝对是最恰当的比喻。
She is like a medieval queen. But the difference is she works, as you said, so hard. In the Dos Passos account, he hears one of the women say, she is too thin. That woman is working herself to death. And even at this point, people are sort of saying, this is why I thought of Catherine of Siena, the saint that we did a podcast about last year.
她就像一位中世纪的女王。但不同之处在于，正如你所说，她工作得太辛苦了。在多斯·帕索斯的描述中，他听到其中一个女人说，她太瘦了。那个女人简直是在拼命工作。甚至在那个时候，人们就已经开始这样说了，这就是为什么我想到了锡耶纳的凯瑟琳，也就是我们去年做过播客的那位圣徒。
There was something almost a bit manic and a bit unhealthy about the drive when everyone else just says, okay, enough now, let's go home. She's like, no, we're going to stay till the small hours, seeing more people, doing more good, all of this kind of thing. Something almost… Well, you might say self-mortifying. Self-mortifying, exactly.
当其他人都在说，好了，现在够了，我们回家吧的时候，那种驱动力几乎带有一种狂热和不健康的气息。她却说，不，我们要留到凌晨，见更多的人，做更多的好事，诸如此类。这种感觉几乎……嗯，你可能会说是自我折磨。自我折磨，完全如此。
And when Dos Passos describes it, it's a tableau. It's a kind of ritual. There is something religious about it almost. There is a sort of sense that she is playing a part, that she plays day in, day out. There is a ritualized quality to it. And she even has a new outfit. So she starts to dress like a kind of a nun,
当多斯·帕索斯描述它时，它就像是一幅画。这是一种仪式。它几乎带有一种宗教色彩。有一种感觉，她是在扮演一个角色，日复一日地扮演。它具有某种仪式化的特质。她甚至换上了一套新衣服。所以她开始像修女一样穿衣，
wearing black suits, looking more and more gaunt. She sweeps her hair back, so no more of the sort of piled up hair. And she looks austere and serious and dedicated. And of course, the other thing that we've alluded to before is people will come in with open wounds. They're filthy and they have open wounds. They maybe have leprosy or they have some skin disease or whatever so that's very much the part of a saint i suppose she is absorbing into herself all kinds of archetypes that have an incredible cultural resonance right and obviously these these archetypes are ones that you know i mean she's bound to draw on because that's part of the culture that she comes from so she always said
穿着黑色的套装，看起来越来越憔悴。她把头发向后梳，不再盘起头发。她看起来严肃、认真且充满奉献精神。当然，我们之前提到的另一件事是，人们会带着敞开的伤口走进来。他们很脏，身上有开放性伤口。他们可能患有麻风病或某些皮肤病之类的，所以这非常符合圣徒的形象，我想她正在将各种具有不可思议文化共鸣的原型融入自身，对吧？显然，这些原型是她必然会汲取的，因为那是她出身的文化的一部分；所以她总是说
she wasn't what was it a candle lick candle licker. So she wasn't a kind of, you know, she wasn't a church going Catholic, but she clearly is very Catholic. Her impulses, her concerns. I mean, I agree that the comparisons with Catherine of Siena are kind of intriguing. And the emphasis that even the rhetoric that she uses, so it's not just in the soap operas. One of the accounts, I think it's Joseph Page's book about Peron, he says, it seems sometimes that the aim of the foundation under the Peronist regime was not so much the construction of public works as the generation of emotion. And this constant emphasis on love, obviously a very Christian word. An American reporter said, in Argentina today, there's love, love, love. Love makes the Per perrons go around their whole act is based on it they are madly passionately nationally in love they conduct their affair with
她不是什么，那叫什么来着，舔蜡烛的。所以她不是那种，你知道的，不是那种经常去教堂的天主教徒，但她显然非常天主教。她的冲动，她的关切。我的意思是，我同意将她与锡耶纳的凯瑟琳进行比较是相当耐人寻味的。而且她所强调的甚至她使用的修辞，所以不仅是在肥皂剧里。其中一份记录，我想是约瑟夫·佩吉关于贝隆的书，他说，有时似乎贝隆主义政权下基金会的目标与其说是建设公共工程，不如说是激发情感。而这种对爱的不断强调，显然是一个非常基督教的词汇。一位美国记者说，今天的阿根廷充斥着爱、爱、爱。爱让贝隆夫妇的世界转动，他们的整个行为都基于此，他们疯狂地、充满激情地、国家般地相爱，他们公开地与
the people quite openly you know that again that sense that she's she's constantly talking about love in a way that politicians you know they don't do because they sound a bit weird but churchmen do or saints do and it's the love i suppose most obviously of the virgin for sinners for the poor for the sick for the suffering and peron is kind of cast as a godlike figure she can play the role of the mother of god she can then have you seen the nicknames that people gave the titles the lady of hope the mother of the innocents the standard bearer of the descamisados and the one that you mentioned the the bridge of love. I mean, all of these are obviously coming out of a society where Catholic... Saturated in kind of Marian devotion.
人民进行着这场精神恋爱，你知道，那种感觉，她不断地以一种政治家通常不会做的方式谈论爱，因为听起来有点奇怪，但神职人员或圣徒会这样做。我想，这最明显的就是圣母对罪人、穷人、病人和受苦之人的爱，而贝隆则被塑造成一个神一般的人物，她可以扮演神母的角色，她然后——你见过人们给她的那些绰号和头衔吗？希望女士、无辜者之母、无衣者的旗手，还有你提到的那个——爱的桥梁。我的意思是，所有这些显然都源于一个天主教……充满玛利亚崇拜色彩的社会。
Marian, yeah, exactly. Exactly. She casts herself quite freely as the high priestess of a cult. She says, sometimes I think that Peron... I i mean perron is a man who she sleeps with she knows perron is a normal person but she says i sometimes think that perron ceased to be an ordinary man and became an ideal incarnate where he does leave flowers on her pillow he does but i don't want to give anything away but i mean i don't think my wife would say that of me that i was no longer yeah but you're not perron dominic no it's an idea i don't even believe tom that your wife would say that of you yeah but equally i i am not i am not the helmsman of my country would sadie say if you perron is everything tom is everything
玛利亚崇拜，是的，完全如此。完全如此。她非常随性地把自己塑造成一个邪教的高女祭司。她说，有时候我觉得贝隆……我的意思是，贝隆是一个与她同床共枕的男人，她知道贝隆是一个普通人，但她说，有时我觉得贝隆不再是一个普通人，而是变成了一个肉身化的理想，他确实会在她的枕头上留下一束花。他会的，但我不想剧透任何东西，不过我的意思是，我不认为我妻子会这样评价我，说我不再是……是的，但你又不是贝隆，多米尼克。这是一种理念，汤姆，我甚至不相信你妻子会那样评价你。是的，但同样地，我不是——我不是我国家的舵手。萨迪会说，如果……贝隆是一切，汤姆，是一切。
he is the soul the nerve the hope and the reality of the argentine people there is only one man here in our movement with his own source of light and that is peron we all feed from his light i mean if somebody said that about me i would call the police i would be i would find that very disturbing but you are i think it's fair to say very much not a peronist figure right thanks and i mean that as a compliment it's positive absolutely as a compliment thank you thank you because obviously it's not I mean it goes back to what we were saying earlier
他是阿根廷人民的灵魂、神经、希望与现实。我们运动中这里只有一个男人拥有他自己的光源，那就是贝隆。我们都沐浴在他的光芒下。我的意思是，如果有人那样评价我，我会报警的。我会觉得那非常令人不安。但你，我觉得可以公平地说，绝对不是一个贝隆主义的人物，对吧？谢谢。我是作为赞美这样说的。这绝对是褒义。谢谢，谢谢，因为这显然不是——这回到了我们之前所说的那样
that Perron is role playing he is self aware that he can kind of see the humorous aspect of this and that Evita doesn't
贝隆是在角色扮演，他有自我意识，他能看到这一事件中幽默的一面，而伊薇塔却没有。
Evita takes it all absolutely seriously is not remotely cynical and really believes it and that's obviously very very potent because she brings the sincerity
伊薇塔把这一切都绝对当真，一点也不愤世嫉俗，她是真心相信的，这显然非常非常有感染力，因为她带来了真诚，
and Perron brings the calculation yeah I think that's exactly genius combination I think it she brings the sincerity and Perron brings the calculation. Yeah, I think that's exactly. Genius combination. I think it's a brilliant combination. I think you're absolutely right. I think it's one thing that her critics said the Borges type people got wrong. They saw her as purely cynical.
而贝隆带来了算计。是的，我认为这绝对是天才的结合。我认为她带来了真诚，而贝隆带来了算计。是的，我认为正是如此。天才的组合。我认为这是一个绝妙的组合。我想你完全说对了。我认为她的批评者——比如博尔赫斯那类人——搞错了一件事，他们把她看作是纯粹愤世嫉俗的人。
And I mean, Borges is always making jokes about her being a prostitute and stuff and saying she's just a cynical Ari Vist and stuff. Actually, I think she genuinely believes in her message. She couldn't play that part for so long with such dedication. Completely, and drive herself literally into the grave, as we will surely be seeing. So actually, just to sort of step back a bit from Ava and talk about the regime, these have been so far quite good years for Argentina. They're making tons of money from selling all their steaks to Europe. Most people are better off than they've ever been. And the government is giving people more benefits than they've ever had. So pensions, and they're building orphanages, they're building schools, they're doing all these kinds of things.
我的意思是，博尔赫斯总是在开玩笑说她是个妓女什么的，说她只是个愤世嫉俗的社会攀附者之类的。实际上，我认为她真心相信自己的信息。她不可能以这样的奉献精神扮演那个角色那么长时间。完全如此，并且真的把自己累死，正如我们接下来肯定会看到的。所以事实上，稍微从阿娃身上退一步，来谈谈这个政权，到目前为止，对于阿根廷来说，这些年还算不错。他们通过向欧洲出售所有的牛排赚取了大量的金钱。大多数人的生活状况比以往任何时候都要好。政府提供给人们的福利也比以往任何时候都多。比如养老金，他们建立孤儿院、学校，做所有这些事情。
Peron is not at this point, he's just not a dictator. He has been elected in a popular mandate in what everybody agreed was a fair election. He has a majority in the Congress. The Congress is passing laws. However, I think there is a sense as you get towards the end of the 1940s that he is moving in a direction that actually today in the 21st century is very familiar, what you might call a sort of Orban-Erdogan direction. So elective authoritarianism. Exactly. So if you're one of his opponents, you're not shot, you're not put in prison, you know, no one inserts a cattle prod into you or any of the
贝隆在此时并不是一个独裁者。他是在大家都认为是公平的选举中通过民意授权当选的。他在国会中拥有多数席位。国会在通过法律。然而，我认为随着20世纪40年代末的临近，有一种感觉，即他正在朝一个在21世纪的今天非常熟悉的方向发展，你可能会称之为欧尔班-埃尔多安式的方向。也就是选举式威权主义。完全如此。所以如果你是他的反对者，你不会被枪决，不会被投入监狱，你知道，没有人把电极棒插入你的身体，或者做任何
things that are later very familiar. But you might get sacked from the National Library. Like Borges. Which is what happens to Borges. Yes, exactly. And sent off to become a poultry inspector. Exactly. Or, I mean, the famous thing. Even though he's blind. He must have been a terrible poultry inspector. Is that the Jockey Club, the Fancy though he's blind, so he must have been a terrible military inspector. ...is that the jockey club, the fancy gentleman's club, apparently set up a fish market right outside, which is very annoying, obviously, for all the people in their nice suits who are going in for a little digestif or something.
后来变得非常熟悉的事情。但你可能会被国家图书馆解雇。就像博尔赫斯一样。这就是博尔赫斯遭遇的下场。是的，完全如此。然后被派去当家禽检查员。完全如此。或者，也就是那件著名的趣事。尽管他是瞎的。他一定是个糟糕透顶的家禽检查员。那就是赛马俱乐部，那个高档绅士俱乐部，显然在门外建了一个鱼市，这对于所有那些穿着漂亮西装进去喝点餐后酒之类的人来说，显然非常烦人。
There's also occasionally when upper-class protesters get arrested, they are deliberately locked up with prostitutes. Yeah, exactly, that kind of thing. So it's sort of humiliations rather than anything more serious. protesters get arrested they are deliberately locked up with prostitutes yeah exactly that kind of thing so it's sort of humiliations rather than anything more serious but if you're a critic of peron's government you would say look there are actually some quite disturbing signs so as time goes on as so often the way he's getting rid of some of the more independent-minded people around him which he does he purges the supreme. The old guard are disappearing, being replaced by people who are slavishly loyal. Opposition newspapers, the most famous one is a newspaper called La Prensa, which is a kind of
此外，有时上流社会的抗议者被捕时，他们会被故意和妓女关在一起。是的，完全如此，诸如此类的事情。所以这是一种羞辱，而不是更严重的事情。抗议者被捕时他们会被故意和妓女关在一起是的完全如此诸如此类的事情所以这是一种羞辱而不是更严重的事情但如果你是贝隆政府的批评者你会说看这里其实有一些相当令人不安的迹象所以随着时间的推移就像通常发生的那样他在摆脱身边一些更有独立思想的人，他确实这么做了，他对最高法院进行了清洗。老卫士们正在消失，取而代之的是那些盲目忠诚的人。反对派报纸，其中最著名的是一份名为《新闻报》（La Prensa）的报纸，这是一种贵族精英报纸。它们正在被接管。还有一件事我认为相当不祥，那就是不敬罪法。侮辱公众人物的尊严可能会被判处三年监禁。这是一项旧法律，以前有一个辩护理由，你可以说，但我说的是真的。现在这一条被拿掉了。所以即使你所说的是真的，也不成为辩护的理由。这在我看来非常像普京的俄罗斯。是的，确实如此。这对阿娃的家人来说也是个好消息，不是吗？因为胡安依然活跃在政坛，而且他依然贪杯。而她的母亲已经成了一个狂热的赌徒。有一个政府官员的工作就是为她筹集
patrician elite newspaper. They are being taken over. And there is also something that I think is quite ominous, which is a law of disrespect. You can be imprisoned for three years for insulting the dignity of public figures. This is an old law and there used to be a defence that you could say, but what I'm saying is true. And now that is taken out. So even if what you've said is true, it is no defence. And that seems very Putin's Russia to me. Yeah, that is. It's also good news for Ava's family, isn't it? Because Juan is still very much on the scene and he's drinking deep. And her mother has become a massive gambler. And there's a government official whose job is to keep her in
筹码。所以，我的意思是，这显然没有那么阴险，但它我猜是一个标志：尽管伊薇塔累死累活地分发缝纫机，但她并不排斥顺便搞点腐败来帮衬她的家人。随着时间的推移，这个政权变得越来越腐败，这类政权的发展都是不可避免的。当然，当阿根廷经济状况极佳时，没有人会在意。没有人关心。一旦情况开始变糟——这将在20世纪50年代发生——人们就会开始担心这种腐败。
chips. So, I mean, that's obviously less sinister, but it is, I suppose, a marker of the fact that even though Evita is flogging herself into the grave, handing out sewing machines, she is not averse to a bit of, on the side, a bit of corruption helping her family. The regime is becoming more and more corrupt as it goes on, as is inevitable with that kind of regime. And of course, when Argentina is doing very well, no one minds. No one cares. As soon as things start to go badly, which they will in the 1950s, people will start to worry about this corruption.
它将成为一个问题。在胡安·贝隆之前，阿根廷总统是有任期限制的。根据宪法，你不能连续参加两届为期六年的总统竞选。贝隆和他国会中的那些马屁精们修改了宪法，以便他现在可以再次参选。当我们进入20世纪50年代时，最初的传言开始流传，不仅他将再次参选，而且作为他的副总统，作为他的竞选伙伴1950年，1月9日，她在所有这些传言甚嚣尘上之际，前往一个名为阿韦利亚内达的地区，那是布宜诺斯艾利斯的一个郊区，去主持一个开幕仪式。
It will become an issue. Now, until Juan Perón, there were term limits for Argentine presidents. Under the constitution, you could not run for two consecutive six-year terms. Perón and his sort of lackeys in the Congress, they amend the constitution so he can now run again. And as we enter the 1950s, there are the first whispers that not merely is he going to run again, but as his vice president, as his running 1950, the 9th of January, she goes, with all of these rumors swirling around, she goes to open in a district called Avellaneda, a suburb of Buenos Aires.
她去为出租车司机工会的新总部揭幕，这是他们建立的工会之一，是他们的一种客户工会。那天天气非常非常热。显然，正值阿根廷盛夏的高峰。她准备剪彩，突然感到一阵刺痛，随即晕倒，被紧急送往医院。没有人知道她出了什么毛病。汤姆，整个国家都屏住了呼吸。她能活下来吗？还是说，她要成为阿根廷总统了？谁知道呢？正如我们的听众也将不得不屏住呼吸一样，
She goes to open a new headquarters of the Taxi Drivers Union, which is one of these unions that they have set up, one of their kind of client unions. It's a really, really hot day. Obviously, it's the height of the Argentine summer. She's going to be cutting the ribbon, and she suddenly has this stabbing pain and she faints and she is rushed to hospital. And no one knows what is wrong with her. Tom, the country holds its breath. Is she going to live or what? Or is she going to become president of Argentina? Who knows? As our listeners will have to hold their breath,
除非，当然，他们是《余下的历史》俱乐部的会员，那样的话他们就可以收听下一集，找出问题所在，看看伊薇塔是否成为了副总统。如果你想这样做，但你还不是俱乐部的会员，你可以前往 therelishistory.com 并注册。或者除此之外，我们的下一集很快就会发布，我确信。我们正在接近这个非凡故事的尾声，必须指出的是，即便在
unless, of course, they are members of the Restless History Club, in which case they can listen to the next episode, find out what the problem is, find out whether Evita becomes vice president or not. And if you would like to do that, but you're not a member of the club, you can go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up there. Or otherwise, our next episode will be coming out, I'm sure, very soon. And we're approaching the end game of this extraordinary story and it has to be said that even when
伊薇塔死后，这桩疯狂的闹剧也没有停止，事实上它愈演愈烈了。没有人比你更喜欢这句话了。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
evita dies the mad shit does not stop indeed it intensifies nobody loves that phrase more than you Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想收听无广告的剧集、独家番外并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想收听无广告节目、获得额外单集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。